giving you the same financial advice
your grandmother did only we keep our
teeth in this is the Dave Ramsey show in
the lobby of Ramsey solutions keep and
Denise are with us hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome welcome where are you
from Southwest Florida Southwest Florida
like Tampa area about two hours south
Cape Coral Florida oh yeah okay
beautiful area mmm and who's the young
man with you that's our son Gavin and
Gavin is how old he's eight very cool
and you guys are here to do your
debt-free scream yes and how much have
you paid off two hundred and eighty
thousand oh all right there's a story
here how long did that take about five
years okay very cool and your household
income range during that five years
anywhere from forty five thousand to
this past year I think we're just high
two fifty that's a little bit of a jump
so what do you guys do for a living
tell me about that income jump well I am
a billing manager for a medical office
mm-hmm and he's a land surveyor land
surveyor
yeah and we're so tightly tied with
construction and real estate that when
the market melted down in Florida and
across the country that I lost my job we
realized we had Chinese drywall in our
house and Oh figured what a great time
to start a business so yeah we can't get
you can't find work and dry walls and I
oh my gosh unbelievable okay and so
you've grown a very successful and
survey business as the economy rebounded
very very successful here over the past
couple of years and we hope that stays
like it but yeah you know grateful for
every moment that we get when it's like
this
amen amen take it whoa make hay while
the Sun shines
there we go so the 280,000 what kind of
debt was this about three thousand I
think it was in credit cards and all the
rest was mortgage paid off your house
yes so you went from a complete debacle
with careers and Chinese drywall to now
paid off house yes yes sir Wow so what
happened at is is that what drove you to
do this stuff the the Chinese wall
of you they don't know that that's how
that's a ten-year-old problem I'm an I'm
gonna heard that in a long time yeah we
had some counterfeit is only way I know
how to describe it bad quality drywall
that was sold in and put up and then it
just fell apart
right pretty much yeah and it pretty
some pretty deadly yeah not deadly but
you know bad gasses and stuff that ate
up all the electronics in the house and
in safe place to live yeah but we think
that him losing his job was a good thing
because had he had a job there thought
of like do you move move out and just
let the house go to the mortgage go to
the bank or or not and so we didn't
really have a choice so we just stayed
in the house and luckily we moved out
with his mom for a couple months and
then found out we got chosen to have her
house fixed oh really
yeah part of the pilot program through
the manufacturer okay we were blessed
very blessed okay so you didn't end up
right in the whole track no no they just
paid to have the house rebuilt but we
still had to pay the mortgage
okay yeah we still owed the note so Wow
well that's good news
okay and so all of that is what drove
you to decide to get out of debt or was
there another part of the story I'm
missing I think it's losing my job
really it's what kinda woke us up that
we needed needed to do something you
know quit the habits the bad habits that
you know spending and accumulating stuff
you know we didn't need stuff you know
we needed a change like you say change
our family tree
oh you're awful young for a paid-for
house so what's this house worth now and
350 was what what were real estate
friend back home said that we could sell
the for for want to do right now how
very cool how old are you - I'm 42 24
hade for house how's that feel amazing
weird so what made you think you could
actually go from all of us being in the
hole to a paid-for house yeah and
hearing the people on the radio you know
you're watching that gazelle run it gave
us a lot of hope that you know we could
do it watch it so you were in the
Financial Peace University class yeah
and you're watching the gazelle run that
was favorite part okay it's mine too we
also this year and then a couple years
ago with our church we helped as like a
team leader for the FPU so
kind of keeps us motivated yeah
especially with everything paid off
you're like okay I've got all this money
you know what do I do and you want to go
back in that same that bit you know same
temper yeah I'll never ever again no
matter what yeah very cool well thank
you for leading the class it's got to be
inspiring for the people going to the
class the 40 year old couple but their
house paid for oh my gosh I mean this is
wonderful very very cool
so out of this whole process other than
the job loss and the house remodel and
that kind of stuff but the the money
management process what was the hardest
part for you all I think just knowing
that at any moment you can just you know
lose track of what you're supposed to be
doing and all the other outside
influences just staying motivated and
focused on what you want to accomplish
afraid of backsliding to your old ways
yeah okay a lot of beautiful waterfront
and Southwest Florida it's hard not to
you know go out and buy a boat and all
the other things that everybody else in
the neighborhood's doing so you know
staying focused very tough oh yeah yeah
there's a lot of boat peer pressure that
could happen that could happen that
could happen on a lake - I can speak
from experience I've got a really nice
boat but I passed one the other day that
was a nicer doesn't change anything
oh my goodness you guys are incredible
oh very fun so what advice do you give
people who want to get out of debt what
are the keys to doing it communicate you
have to communicate as a couple and be
on the same page as far as your budget
and where you're spending your money
were you not communicating before no but
we both this way forced us to say okay
what do we as a couple want to
accomplish we communicate really well
okay but you just had to get detailed
okay yeah I think on finances I think in
other areas of our life I think we
communicate well but prior to financial
piece I think that maybe we weren't as
communicating as well as we both or you
know it sounds like yeah it's it's
detailed stuff and you go what really
that's how that works
oh my gosh you know that kind of stuff
happens when you start unpacking the
entire suitcase yeah yeah where to go
very cool you guys I'm very proud of you
and we this was we had our son draw the
picture of the house and this is what we
use to keep yourself motivated
we were having a stewardship campaign
with this hanging up in our wall and I
like it I like it that is it's a our own
little version that's right very good
well good job Gavin you set the tone for
the whole campaign well done well done
well we're gonna give you guys a signed
copy of retire inspire number one
bestseller from Chris Hogan because
that's the next step is to continue to
build wealth and live and give like no
one else and thanks for leading
Financial Peace University after having
gone through it that's going to be very
inspiring you have no idea of you you
just have to think back in your mind to
how scared you were and how how messed
up and you didn't know what to do and
then you sat down and somebody showed
you you could do it and it really wasn't
that hard to understand and you believed
and you could do it that's what you're
doing for other people when you're
leading these classes so thank you for
doing this thank you all right hang on
and when we're done and Kelly we'll make
sure you get a copy of that or are some
of the folks in the bookstore Dorothy or
someone will get you a copy of it here
on site so Keith and Denise and Gavin
the Tampa Florida area a couple hours
south anyway $280,000 paid off five
years bouncing everything baby they
don't have a house payment they're weird
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
I love it I love it very well done you
guys absolutely fabulous that is how
it's done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in economy